my question is marketing last year I did
an online somatic breath work and I
didn't really know how to Market and I
only have one person show up people
don't know who I am yet so you have any
tips on how to Market in person for Live
Events and online so the fastest way if
you want to fill it up is through
Partnerships unless you got a big ad
budget that you're going to start
spending it's Partnerships whose space
are you doing it out of the gym I go to
can you put flyers up in the gym yeah I
can the people who are going to come to
your event they're paying you to come to
the workshop yes could the gym help
promote it and take a cut yeah I'm sure
I can work with her yeah they email it
to their list then they get a commission
okay yeah maybe you're going to need a
commission maybe they'll just do it for
you yeah can you go and be at the front
of the gym for the week before and talk
to people that come in and have flyers
and share about the workshop that you
have coming up have an announcement
board you can put something up on it's
like how can we use the location to help
promote because there's foot traffic
coming in every day people coming to the
gym every day how can we help get our
message to them and incentivize the gym
maybe they do it because they just love
you maybe they do it because you're
you're renting space maybe they do it
because they're making a cut all of the
instructors all of the the people who
are you know personal trainers there
getting to know them so that they're
saying in the class potentially that
you've got this thing coming up
so that's the easiest one next you go to
all of your the local media
the local newspaper the local Facebook
groups the local whatever and get to
know the reporters like it's a lot
easier to get into where where do you
live uh Northern California okay like
Eureka like northern northern okay yeah
um I'm Canadian so I don't really know
my U.S geography I was thinking
Sacramento but but you're closer okay so
you're in Eureka California yeah great
yeah like there's some newspaper for
Eureka California
that that
you know you know it's not going to try
to get into the LA Times
you're trying to get into the Eureka
newspaper okay it's a lot easier yeah so
what reporter is talking about the
events in Eureka right now get to know
her or him and let them know that you've
got because your ideally this is an
ongoing thing it's not just this one
event yeah a weekly event
right so build them those connections
help
um
any Facebook groups dedicated to Eureka
okay any business owners who value
relationships right like
um if you're gonna do a series so it's
like this is a one-off uh
this is a one-off event but then you
have a you is it like they can then sign
up for nine weeks with you or something
what happens I I was planning to do like
once a month
okay so but what you can do is sell it
sell it as a manual package
um for the first one is hey if you want
the next 12 months how much does the
first one cost
uh thirty dollars Okay so
uh
uh cool so they spent 30 bucks to come
in great
you're going to be doing a year of these
once a month and they can they can buy
the whole thing for 300 bucks
once a month on the first Wednesday of
every month or whatever you're going to
be doing yeah so that you have a way to
make more money coming in
and if you made some deals so for
example who values relationships in
Eureka you've got real estate agents
go make connection with all the real
estate agents and offer them uh the
first event for free
somebody signs up as a as a thing they
always give gift baskets and whatever
when somebody buys a house with them
cool they can give a somatic breath Work
Workshop
that's I probably increase my price
anyway you know but whatever that's 30
bucks yeah yeah
um that then is free because for you you
have the class you've rented the studio
whether you have one person or 20 people
it's like the same cost for you until
you know what the capacity is of your
place
uh that small gym
12.
oh okay well great so
whoever your closest real estate agent
friends are that's who you start with
and
they get to give it out for free to
their clients
the client so at the first one maybe you
have six people who are free from the
real estate agent great six of them are
from the gym that you helped you know
work a deal with and six of them are
from your real estate agent then the six
you can then say hey well if you like
this I have a year of this
first bucks so we're selling the future
ones okay so it's all local
relationships right it's like it's a gym
it's the real estate agents it's the
local Media newspapers you know that
local is a lot easier to work than
being the the face of somatic breathing
for America yeah right
um
yeah so that's the easy way to and then
and then we need to raise our prices and
then we need to get a gym that can
handle more than 12 people yeah yeah
those are cool to have right those are
good problems to have yeah cool so I'll
stop with my getting down with my local
people first
yeah yeah it's a great start and you
build a community and then people want
to come back and that could be a weekly
thing instead of a monthly thing
right like how do you
how do you well you had if it was let's
say 50 bucks and you had 20 people it's
a thousand bucks like how do you make a
thousand bucks a week or two thousand
bucks a week
from doing workshops
fun
yeah
it is and also I want to do two uh in
the future is
um I guess meeting uh Retreats being
like a guest to do like breath work for
you know like a mindset Retreat or
whatever Retreat so I would get build a
relationship with other coaches that
does
right a great way to start with the
treats is you you offer to be a speaker
at somebody else's retreat
they are look at other Retreats and say
hey if you're doing this Retreat I'm
happy to
to do my part and do breath work there
okay right like now that you're part of
Evan's uh
what was it you did like his his
Mastermind or something or his speech
his his challenge it was his uh
conference to get high paying clients
great so you you went to his conference
now you get a better sense of how
conferences are run yeah and the movie
makers you get a sense of how uh
membership programs are run
go to other people's Retreats and
offered us to do your breath work even
for free just to see how Retreats are
run yeah because that's a great upsell
for you on top of the breath work that
you're doing right so that you've got
your breath work classes that are once a
week
um and then you can that's that's 50
bucks an hour and then you can sell your
three thousand dollar Retreat or five
thousand dollar Retreat like this
business I know pretty well just from
the salsa world that's that's what we do
like Tanya's here she's proud of you
know Toronto Dan salsa we'll have 40
people times three yeah we'll have like
120 people
um a night come in and learn salsa
dancing and we teach
well we want to be at seven days a week
we don't have the instructors yet for it
but I think we're like five days a week
teaching salsa classes so you may not
want that level of uh
commitment but if you taught how long is
a workshop
uh an hour and a half total so like if
you did
if you did three hours
where you did an hour and a half for a
group to solve x and then an hour and a
half for the more advanced group or to
solve a certain other kind of thing and
then in three hours once a week
if that's making you you know a couple
thousand bucks every week
it's a pretty good business you know I I
guess I didn't think about the money
part of adding that up but it makes
sense yeah
yeah well I mean it's just it's nice to
make money yeah yeah yeah you know we
need to make money it's we're building a
mission and we're having an impact but
if if it's even something small like
that like if you're making a couple
thousand bucks a week from
from
doing work that you love which is breath
work for three hours
once like in one one time slot per week
like that's good like that helps support
whatever you're doing it helps help to
make you feel like the work you're doing
matters helps build a lot of connections
and local Resources with people you get
to see the impact of the work that
you're doing like it's just a lot of
great things start to happen because you
built that up and in the salsa world you
know you did the same thing we started
with one class renting from a gym that's
how TDS started was renting from a gym
uh for one hour a week but then became
two hours a week then became a whole
night three hours a week that then
became a bigger gym because a gym was
too small to handle like 12 people you
don't go rent out a place that can
handle 100 people if you have five
people showing up right this is a great
start but especially as you build
momentum great thing about the breath
workers like people will they'll need it
it's like you have to come back for
does not even um you know like in the
salsa world you get better and better
and better and you don't want to come
back to the beginner classes because
you're a more advanced dancer but like
you you just need it yeah you need it
every week
or you need it every month yeah you know
forever and so you'll build this really
loyal group of people who want to keep
coming back and getting coached by you
and working with you and each other you
know to get this family people who
believe in somatic breathing and all the
benefits yeah so yeah locals it's easier
to build uh
you know fifty hundred thousand dollar
business local it's hard to build a
million two million dollar business
local yeah but that's the start yeah you
know that gives the foundation and then
go and do much bigger things cool thank
you so much that gave me a lot of
clarity and I will start going local
first and getting that started and my
question is that um your build to serve
book has been my Foundation my why and
I've built a small business with
teenagers for the past three years and
now I want to write a help but for
parents teams and my question for you is
do you think it's better if I offered
um you know worksheets that are
downloadable as well as because I want
to make the book where they can put
paper to pencil as well or should I just
make the book paper to pencil to make it
a little more exclusive that you have to
buy the book and not get the worksheets
or should I do both
this is great so start with this
what's going to be the most effective
thing for people who are reading the
book like what's going to get them the
most results I think if it's paper to
pen because some of the
so do that just the book itself you
start with what's going to be the most
effective thing like what's your goal is
to actually help people make a ship why
do you write a book because you want to
have an impact you want people to take
the knowledge that you've got from
teaching and helping students for many
years and they may never meet you but
somebody from across the country is
going to read that book and have their
life transformed right like that's why
any of us write books
right so you start with like what's
going to get the student the best result
and then we can be strategic around it
so
it's a good idea to have something that
I can download so that you can capture
their email address so that when you
write your next book or when you're
asking for Amazon reviews or you've got
a speaking event or whatever the next
thing is that you're trying to do you
have email addresses to be able to send
people
the problem with most books is you don't
know people buy but you don't know who
they are
so it is a smart thing to do to have
something that can be downloaded
so you can capture email address but
should it be this thing maybe not like
it could be something else that then you
add in extra
so if you say that writing pen the paper
inside the book is the best way for them
to get results then that's what you put
in the book because you want your
students or your readers to get results
then in addition you have something else
that is a guide that is uh bonus
chapters that is stuff that didn't make
it into the actual book that is you uh
you know transcripts of you coaching
people additional stories or tools that
I can get
from the book
okay
yes makes perfect sense
that's great that's exciting and when
does the book come out
all right all right Connie so when are
we when are we finishing the book Connie
December on the shelves all right let's
go Connie we're cheering you on thank
you for joining and asking the question
we appreciate you being here
that it's something that's
traveling me and I kind of no no I don't
know how why it's happening and uh it's
um some time ago like two weeks ago I I
was interviewed by one of the top
channels in my in my country they
interviewed me um for a for an opinion
about
and yeah I did it like it was very nice
I didn't expect it it was it was
something I I feel is good but then I
cannot share it
what do you mean you can't hear it I
cannot share it like in in social media
they sent me the interview they you know
they they they
the video but
I I haven't posted it
because it's in a different language
well it's in Spanish yeah but it's I
don't know if it's the Spanish thing or
I don't know why I feel like
shy about posting it in it I think it's
something good yeah it was a good
interview but I don't know what's
what's there why I'm not doing it the
way through is through
so you have to post it
and uh
I would pull even just to get it out I
would just post a Spanish version of it
and then work on posting one with
English
captions on it
like even if it doesn't do well the fact
that you're afraid to share it means you
have to share it and then you can make a
video even talking about how you're
afraid to share it because I don't
really know why is that
shouldn't be it's something that we all
go through right I mean it's fear of
judgment it's fear of people looking at
you it's fear of you you know getting
this fear of being seen and fear of not
being seen both at the same time
but the way through is through like this
this will show up in ongoing multiple
ways just at different levels right we
just talk about Brandon burchard's event
well what what happens when you get
called to go speak at Brennan's event
you're going to be afraid okay so why
same thing afraid of being seen afraid
of not being seen
but the way through is through so the
best thing you can do is use the energy
from this and post
like today you post the Spanish version
of it
Peter says he can help you with English
captions great perfect thank you the
world is conspiring to help you and get
this message out
um yeah and then you can work on others
but but you post
anytime you're afraid to post that's why
you have to post because if you don't
then you'll constantly live in that fear
whether this interview or the next
interview or the next interview
yeah
okay and if you want to go deeper then
you share the story like why you're
afraid I'm afraid to share this
but so that's why I have to share this
and that ends up inspiring
lots of other people give them your
willingness to post gives other people
permission to go chase down their thing
whatever they want to accomplish
that's not
to put it thank you let's go Tanya
Pablo's question was serving money how
to set priorities your mindset for
Revenue so
this is a big reason why I wrote built
the serve because a lot of people have a
hard time making money off of their
purpose and you have a hard time asking
and a hard time monetizing as a result
you end up doing the thing
in the evenings and weekends and then
having to have some other job that you
don't like just to pay the bills I know
Zan and I have talked a bunch about
making money on our on our live streams
because Zane has a hard time asking for
money it's like no Zan you got it you
gotta charge this is how much it is we
got to charge you gotta right it doesn't
mean that you still can't give things
away for free
um at every event that I go to when I'm
speaking
there's always uh usually five to ten
percent of people that will give tickets
away for free
um
some people are homeless and you never
know it
you know you never know it by looking at
them that they're homeless
um
so you can still have that as an as an
element as a part of it but you have to
make money because if you're not making
money then you don't
you don't
build your business you don't build your
purpose you don't impact more people
like look at the reach that I'm able to
have
because of the team if this was me Evan
Carmichael part-time doing things I
probably wouldn't even have written this
book
we wouldn't be here talking
and so as I say in the book you know
money has to be in your top five just
not number one
so you have to learn how to make money
off your business you have to because
because otherwise you're stuck with a
job that you hate uh
it just can't be number one it can't be
above everything else so when people
come in we had a guy in our live stream
two days ago I think came in and said
hey I've got a I've got two business
ideas the first one I really you know I
enjoy and I struggle with this and I
want to help other people through it and
then the other one this is hot
opportunity with my cousin like no the
first one
like don't do like hot opportunity with
your cousin that's just not the one but
that's that's how most people start a
business that's that's what most people
they just think they're gonna make a
quick Buck
um as opposed to actually being deeply
connected to it and that's when you end
up losing so it's got to be money's got
to be in your top five just not number
one
does that help probably go deeper since
since you're here that was your topic
does that help you with where you're at
yeah so
sometimes it's kind of a
you know until what is what do you do
what do you do free what you how do you
charge how much do they charge you know
sometimes uh
um I don't know I I help a lot of people
and and I feel that pressure you know
like today finally uh I get all every
day you know I you know I have this
problem you know this help me with this
I'm being helping for it for years you
know but also it just even you have two
people that that many times they they
help me they bring their the issues and
and today with the first time they say
if you wanna
you wanna uh me to answer you just do it
through the YouTube you know so so at
least at least I I don't I used to I
used to do for WhatsApp you know I used
to do it on on the email yeah and now I
say no YouTube and if you don't do it in
YouTube I you know it's just I I feel
like it's hard because the kind of
problem you know one person one woman
was abused and you know she need to
negotiate she need to do another person
solve their business and this and so
people that that financially they're not
stable so I don't know but uh yeah so so
let's get super tactical here one in
your bio of all your social accounts we
need to have something that talks about
what they can buy
so it could be hire me for coaching it
could be check out my new book it could
be like whatever you whatever you have
for sale this is what I told Zane to do
because Zan will just give everything
away spend all his time for free and and
just love on everybody it's like Zayn
you need to make money you got to do
this so when he started doing uh his
build to serve Readers Club that um that
we launched
as he gets better at going through the
book and coaching
the idea is to train him to be a built
to serve coach and help people who go
deeper because I'm not I'm not coaching
I'm not doing coaching consultant
services I don't I don't want to do it
but Zane does so that's got to be in
your bio you got to let people know that
it's available and in the Facebook post
we talk about here's this free group
that we're launching that you can be a
part of and if you want to go deeper
with me here's I also do coaching and
here's the link
so you have you have it as part of your
default messaging so think about your
social media accounts think about your
email wherever you could potentially
talk about yourself I want you to put in
I need people to know that you have
something to sell
like this is this is the advice of
people who struggle some people are just
overselling selling everything as a
sales pitch right that's that's what you
probably want to avoid becoming and
you're afraid that you might be judged
like that so
uh step number one in your social bio I
need to know like whatever what's what
are you selling Pablo are you selling
coaching you're selling a training what
are you selling yeah selling coaching
programs that are different different
time of the year like in March with the
next problem yeah so so something in
your bio that says DM me for coaching
you see right DM me for leadership coach
you know DME for whatever specific
coaching
um yeah just so that it's because you're
not gonna you're not gonna offer it by
default so I want to see it in the bio
so people know that you're doing it
um the next thing is if it's
uh free then make them go through some
hoops
you're spending your time on it make
make them have to do something so
telling them to ask you on YouTube is a
is is a hoop
um some people on mine
uh will be hey join us live on Instagram
join us live on sorry join us live on
YouTube
for the live stream that I do with with
Zan and Drew so somebody asked me a
question on Instagram uh and it's going
to be a long one I just respond to say
hey let's get into it on on my YouTube
live we're going live tonight at six
o'clock join us
and if they're not willing to do that
like they have to they have to show up
right they've got to own their step a
little bit
um we've had a guy who comes who's come
like eight times or something to our
live stream named Mike who keeps asking
the same questions over and over and
over again it's like Mike like he's
always asking purpose really the
questions so Mike did you get Bill to
serve yet like you have to get we're
going to help you Zan's gonna do a free
one-on-one session with you Zan offered
but you have to you have to get a copy
built to serve
buy it on Amazon get the free version
like sign up for an audio audible trial
and get the free audio book anything
like you have to all your questions are
on purpose the answers are in built to
serve you have to go pick it up
and you know Zen doesn't get anything
from it right if if we get a sale from
Amazon woohoo right anything Zayn's not
making anything but but we're making him
jump through
a hoop like you have to you have to show
if you're gonna show up for them they
have to at least do something to meet
you not even halfway but like take a
step show me that you're committed
show me that you will need to do
something
yeah right so I like that of pushing
them to YouTube or pushing them
somewhere else so it shows you who's
willing to step up and be a little bit
more committed and I'm
I'm happy to if people want to show up
I'm happy to do it most people don't
show up and that's the problem so we had
a guy who wanted to interview me for his
podcast I get
there's tons of interview requests for
podcasts so I said come and join us on
the uh the Youtube live and let's talk
about it so he came to the YouTube live
and and I said
um I appreciate you showing up I'm super
busy right now but talk to me in the new
year and this was in maybe October or
something
uh maybe Zan remembers is October
November uh and then he came back in
January he said hey I'm just reminding
you hey we said January I said you know
what yeah let's do it and and I was I
don't know if I was his first guest or
his like fourth guest he's like right at
the beginning brand new
um and because he was willing to jump
through the Hoops he got
he got access right and so that's
something that at the beginning if you
only get four comments a day it's easy
to respond to everybody but as you grow
that's going to be a real Demand on your
time and so one letting people know that
you have a paid version and then two for
free yes we still do some but you have
to jump through a few Hoops to make it
happen
um and then the third thing I'd offer
out is
having it public
so I'll help you on my Instagram live
come on on my Instagram live and we'll
work I will work through it
um and if they're not willing to you
know option one they're not willing to
pay you option two they're not willing
to
go to another platform and and ask you a
question on YouTube or three they're not
willing to go live with you on Instagram
it's like you gotta you gotta you gotta
show up somewhere like I'm trying here
right you gotta you gotta pull like take
that at least one step in to show me
that you're a little bit committed so
that it's it's a use of your time right
a good use of your time
um so those those three things and that
that will weed out a lot of people but
also bring you the people who are
actually ready for Change and for action
so that you don't feel like you're
wasting your time
yeah yeah welcome Louise welcome aboard
uh what else what do you guys got this
is a it's a it's a small group today so
we can make it intimate yeah I did it I
did it I'm doing the coaching the the
coaching one-on-one you know for for the
free for the free version you know and
that is that is very good you know just
I I fail on my on my group and many many
other people that comment so but
definitely definitely need to put a very
very clear many people know you know but
uh but they just uh because I I've been
trying to build like Community Building
community on Tuesdays where we meet you
know there is like a 150 200 people you
mean for Zoom you know and and and I I
teach them I work I work on this and
after that I stay one hour with everyone
you know but um but uh some sometimes I
just
they just get in no no tired but
um there is a lot of stalkers you know
there's a there's a lady that uh they
would they would appear for everywhere
and you know and and appeared on on my
WhatsApp appearing on this for
everywhere and and she will she will
follow me and my team you know this a
lot you know a lot of weird people you
know
so so so so you know and I'm more
exposed you know like so so I said oh my
God you know like now we need to deal
with it with that and and my my bigger
fear I don't know how you you feel but
my biggest fear is I say no stop it you
know stop it that's enough you know is
if she's going to go and put this
comment bad comment on on on the
Facebook there was another there was a
guy in another country that also was
talking to me last year you know I said
stay man stop it just stop it you know
I'm not going to answer I'm not going to
do that you know that's that's your
issue you know this this you know on on
q1 and make a a nasty comment you know
and so so that's that's my fear that
I don't know it makes sense or no no
most of the time honestly it's just
ignoring
like most of them are just attention
Seekers
it doesn't happen that often but when it
does the the telling somebody to stop it
usually doesn't work usually just get
some even more upset it's just ignoring
until they it's like the the little kid
who's yelling and raging and freaking
out and if you just ignore them they
they calm down or go you know go the
bully go pick on somebody else but if
you
um
yeah I just found like trying to or or
you have to go deep and Coach them like
or you have to like just telling
somebody to stop it is gonna be
you're likely to get them in defensive
mode yeah so you have to either coach be
willing to coach them through it or just
ignore them yeah because otherwise
you're making it worse
yeah yeah I did
but that that's that's like any coaching
if you're gonna dive into somebody's
problem
yeah um
at the beginning you make it worse
and they get defensive like a great
coach if you're not bumping up against
defensiveness you're not doing your job
as a coach you're right you have to be
when you when they start being defensive
that means you actually hit on something
as you're just saying yes yes yes yes
yes yes they're probably not going to
follow through and do anything
it's when they get defensive like ooh
okay that's let's talk about this
because this is your block right here
but to dive into that you have to be
able to pull them out on the other side
you can't just leave them hanging
in in the negativity
so if you don't either one want to put
in the effort to do it or two don't
think you can then it's better not to
address it at all because you're just
going to make it worse yeah
yeah especially when they don't pay you
sure but if you're doing even in the
free sessions I'd say
um
like you do an Instagram live coaching
yeah yeah okay you said you know you you
become yourself extra homework Pablo now
I want you in your Instagram live
sessions to say so normally I do this as
a paid service I'm a I get paid to coach
people on how to
like what do you what what's the
coaching you do leadership
uh negotiation you know how to approach
deals yeah yeah so so normally I do this
kind of work
I get paid to train people on how to
negotiate I work with sales people and
CEOs and entrepreneurs to help them
close more effective deals and that's
that's my business I get paid to do this
but every week on Tuesday I like going
live as a free service for everybody to
be able to learn from and today
we've got whoever
on and I'm going to help him write so
that people know you're still doing the
free thing but that people know that you
do this as a service as well it's not a
hard pitch it's not saying and remember
go hire me
right but you're setting contacts as
you're the expert you get paid for this
in the beginning in the beginning of the
session
yeah in the beginning of the session
um and you can storytell in the middle
if it makes sense
right so you know for example one of my
clients when I was just working with a
client on this yesterday
and his biggest problem was he didn't
know how to X right the fact that you're
saying one of my clients obviously not
gonna say the name and what company
they're from and you can change it I'll
change gender a lot I'll say guy when
it's a girl and opposite because it
doesn't matter who the person is it's
just the story right
um so that people know if you're telling
stories about how you're coaching people
it's not it's not what the just intent
to try to sell people you're you're
telling that story for a reason
but it positions you as a coach and that
oh he does this as a service ah maybe
maybe he can help me negotiate my next
deal
yeah
perfect yeah
I have a question yeah
go ahead so
um I saw you and Cam's uh IG live and
you suggested that he you know do a
30-day challenge well I had already had
this workbook that I had created like
last October November so I decided to
launch it and I did I got two people
that signed up
but I closed the registration on the
25th because I wanted to just like you
know focus and make sure I was walking
them through the workbook and I got the
Facebook group and all that other stuff
but it it prompted me because I've been
really wanting to do like a six-month
program where I walk people through how
I you know changed my mindset and got to
the space that I'm in today
um and I'm really not sure how I want to
do it I don't know if I want to do it
just in 30 day increments you know like
the first month we do mental the second
month we do emotional the third month we
do spiritual or if I just want to offer
it as like a six month program
um I still want to keep the same format
where people come into the Facebook
group and it's a private Facebook group
and I'm there you know offering support
I'm there going over the the questions
every week I'm just needing more
I guess more Direction on how to
effectively Market that or your your
Genius expertise on how I should really
launch that
I just drank down the wrong way
laughs
perfect timing um I think six months is
too long okay
um I think somebody might sign up for it
but I think what I would do is
have your different modules break it up
into six different things
okay and then I need to be able to join
in the next module
so as long as they're not building on
each other right like
module one if it's mindset what's module
one module one is mental mental mental
so what I'm doing is six pillars of um
got it what's what's the name of number
two number two is emotional perfect so I
I need to be able to join at emotional
okay I missed
the mindset or the mental okay they're
connected it's part of this whole thing
but right but they don't have to go they
don't have to flow like that they don't
have to flow I don't feel like if I join
in on the second one I missed out on the
first one
I'm confused the self-contained modules
with challenges if you want like here's
what we're gonna do in the next 30 days
somebody might sign up for all
all six months of them all six pillars
at once right awesome but you can have
that as an option most people won't most
people will just sign up for hey we're
starting our
30-day emotional challenge
to help you get your emotions right for
your business or however you want to
position it and
they could still sign up for the whole
year or for the whole six months right
they just get mental at the end
gotcha
right so I should just keep it rolling
every every so after the six months is
up we start the next seventh month on
mental yep okay and you've learned
something now because you've now gone
through it with people your mental at
seven will be better than mental at one
right and then what I would do is give
some kind of alumni discount say hey you
want to go through this whole thing
again
okay you get it again at like a quarter
of the price or something okay so yeah I
was thinking about doing the six
um different modules and then just group
you know I still want to keep it like at
the same price point you know it's just
the workbook but you get the free
Facebook group Community me there you
know doing lives at the end of the week
and every single day or every week
coming on to go over the challenges or
whatever I have for that week but
um
and then offer so would I just create
one book for the people who want the six
months all together or do I still keep
them separately separate okay and you
give them all six books okay or six PDFs
or whatever yep six PDS Dan and I were
talking about this too with the built to
serve readers group it's like it's got
to be long enough that people can learn
and interact and have fun and and you
know make connections but if the group
starts up every six months it's just it
just takes way too long to get the next
cohort going right so build to serve
does does build like it's hard to jump
in at chapter eight and Zayn's talking
about who I how and they're like what
does that mean you know so the book goes
into sequence but but for you yeah if
you're looking at six month program
that's your best bet you sell the 30
days you sell the six months and then
you sell once they've gone through it to
come back and do it all over again just
as as a refresher at a
discounted rate so just one more thing
so
um really what I was thinking about
doing is like April to October then
taking November off and then starting
back in December would no you just want
me to just go right into November okay
because it's just gonna be some people
sign up on month four but but for them
like I wouldn't even label it because
it's not month four right it's not the
fourth pillar this is this each pillar
is its own thing okay and we go through
six in in six months and then you can
join as an alumni and come back at a
discounted price okay it's got to feel
like a new thing every time okay and
then I didn't miss out on anything okay
I know we gotta go but real quick
Belinda what do you got
um I know you don't like Facebook ads
but like for my products especially my
books I mean I don't know how else to
get it out there without doing an ad
what would you suggest
did I say it on like Facebook guides I
don't mind I don't Facebook ads are
great Facebook itself sucks but but
advertisement Facebook and Instagram ads
can be great
um I think the thing with Facebook with
any advertisement is you have to figure
out the messaging first
so you you have to be talking to people
to know what they connect with
so as an example with with TDS right now
my salsa dancing company uh we're
launching virtual classes because people
can't come in and do
you know in-person salsa classes right
now so Alex is off dming people on
Instagram telling them about a free
class that we have and playing with what
what headline like what what's he typing
into the message and then trying to get
them on a call to talk about it to see
what did they resonate with so when he's
giving his pitch or talking about what
we do what questions do they ask and
what resonates with them like what's the
thing that gets people to then go take
the free class from the conversation
that's a giant waste of time like I I
don't need Alex talking for 30 minutes
to get one person to a free class but
what it what it does that doesn't scale
hard but it gives you the market
feedback to know okay when I use this
phrase when I say this sentence when I
position it like this that's what gets
people to open my message and then go to
the free class
that's what then you turn into an
advertisement
okay at the beginning you don't know
what's going to work and so it's it's a
it's a it's a waste of money or or it's
like a learning experience you either
learn by spending a whole bunch of money
on a bunch of different ideas or you
learn by doing the work and talking to
people
so he just DMS random people not people
that's following him just random people
he's dming people so part of the classes
is is
um personal development so it's like
people who join salsa it's not just to
learn the salsa steps they want to make
an improvement in their life right
they're born they don't like where
they're at right now they want to learn
a new skills on their bucket list
something right so he's looking up
hashtag personal development
and then damning people who are in
Canada the US
and that's it but that's like hitting 50
people a day 100 people a day he does a
text message and then a video like hey
Belinda
and then whatever he can what you know
every day is a slightly different
message
right and just to see what people
connect with that then want to set up a
call with him to then talk about the
free class
again it doesn't scale very hard it's a
lot of time but zero money it's just
your time to do it but as he's getting
feedback for what
what people are connecting with
that goes on your landing page so when
you're talking about the book what's the
headline at the top when you're creating
the ad what's the copy what's the
picture when you know what people are
talking about what what they connect
with it's a lot easier for you to make a
better ad
um so for example when we first came up
with the landing page we used text like
um you deserve an adventure
let let us teach you let's let's have a
great adventure tonight with salsa
dancing and
Adventure wasn't connecting when he said
Adventure on the phone nobody resonated
with it so our headline is wrong we need
to take off Adventure like don't talk
about Adventure anymore so as you're
talking to people you say you deserve an
adventure and you see them do nothing
like okay I didn't I didn't that wasn't
a good okay uh well and then you're kind
of fumbling to come up with whatever
else you can think of and then you say
something like oh that okay great and
then you update the landing page to have
that right so right now it's much more
about
um people feel like they're not
connected they're not connected to
people and that's the messages coming up
so we'll update the page to talk about
connection
and when Alex was talking to more people
it's talking about connection and when
we really dialed that in then it's going
to go to ads Facebook ad Instagram ads
YouTube ads that talk about having
connection right now
because we know that that message works
right
um
if you said hey I've got 10K just to
throw away and test great it's faster
through Facebook ads
uh but you're going to lose a lot of
money versus just talking to potential
customers and seeing what what resonates
with them
the first question that came in on the
poll was how can we focus on one thing
with too much information
so at the beginning of anything
it always can feel overwhelming right if
you're thinking about I want to start on
YouTube I want to start on social media
I want to start writing my book I want
to start like whatever new project you
want to start it always feels
overwhelming it always feels like it's
too big it always feels like you don't
have enough information you can't wrap
your head around what's going on and so
what I like to do is just trying to
figure out where are the boundaries like
what is it that I actually need to learn
and at the beginning I get super
frustrated of any project
just trying to figure out where are the
gates because I'm I love optimizing I
love efficiency I love making things as
tight as possible but at the beginning
creativity is messy and you can't
prematurely optimize something we try to
optimize too soon when you don't know
the boundaries you end up not being able
to make any progress so at the beginning
of any project I will take some time sit
in my frustration and just basically try
to figure out where the gates are around
it so what's the most recent one I think
um figuring out AdWords and advertising
has been one of those things for me in
figuring out okay what ads do I run how
do I put them up what are the placements
what what's the conversions uh the
demographics you know all of the things
that
seem overwhelming at the beginning and
it's frustrating to know which ads to
serve to which audiences and just
testing tests and test and testing until
I kind of get a sense of okay this is
where the gates are and then
make it efficient and squish it down and
optimize it
um so at the beginning for me it's just
research right research plane testing
find don't get so overwhelmed by the the
big picture that you don't take any
action right like what's the smallest
possible thing you can just do to start
gaining momentum and then
that first step seems impossible but
when you go back it's like oh I did that
I did that first step that's pretty cool
now it's Evan Evan's holding up to two
percent I got mine I got mine too make
the two percent happen anyway so I hope
that makes sense right it's taking that
big idea that seems overwhelming that
seems impossible and then finding one
step that you can do today because as
long as you have it as some big dream in
your head that is impossible then you
never take any action and then you know
it's a year later and you still haven't
done the thing yet because it still
seems too impossible and I see it all
the time with entrepreneurs who are
getting started people ask you how do I
get started on YouTube how do I get
started as an author how do I get
started as a speaker and and you think
you've got to have this perfect plan and
the perfect gear and all of this perfect
stuff and then it's a year later and you
still haven't done the thing immediate
action momentum I see Zayn's big smiling
um Zane joined me on my uh three days a
week now I stream League of Legends and
answer business questions and Zen joined
in and they said yeah I'm gonna start
making YouTube videos uh and I think it
was original timeline was it's like next
month or in two months or something so
dude Zan come on tonight make a video
let's go get get your video up uh and
then he did and he got his first video
up and then the second video and then
another video like he's got his phone
out he's gonna make another video right
now
like that's the process and and it's not
going to be perfect being off your phone
and it's and it's not gonna be the the
lighting that you want or the gear that
you want or the background that you want
and your thoughts may not come out as
clearly as you want that's the beginning
like the beginning is supposed to be
messy so don't stress out about having
all the information at the beginning
just go just create like in that
momentum uh you will start getting some
results
um and additional momentum to keep on
building right and
I think a lot of you know my story about
losing that 40 million deal when I was
22 years old of just trying to be too
perfect and have it all planned out and
you know going to Market and then seeing
Oh My Perfect plan was not what people
wanted anyway right like your perfect
version of a YouTube video is not going
to be perfect anyway once you start
creating it's going to change it's going
to take a million different turns
um so the best way to do it is to do it
so to take action against that big idea
so it doesn't just stay
uh doesn't just State an idea for you
forever okay next question Nicolette
said what is your advice on where to
start with content creation if you
haven't started at all
so the easiest place to start is
actually Instagram stories like easy is
easiest easiest way to start is
Instagram stories it's on Instagram
they're 15 seconds Max it's it's meant
to be informal it's meant to be
non-edited it's meant to be kind of
behind the scenes and so if you're
trying to develop that practice of being
a speaker of creating content I
recommend starting like Ground Zero you
start with Instagram stories and try to
find three to ten moments during the day
that you can share you know you where's
my book build to serve right you guys
you guys you have this book if you're in
this group right you've you've got it
hopefully you've read it it's not just
some fancy ornament sitting there on
your desk Zane's got two copies Victor's
got his coffee
I love it Evans I know it's got an
entire Shelf full of uh of books
somewhere there at the top
um
so you know it's it's about starting to
share the way that you think to serve
other people you you're weird you're
different you're I like to say you're a
weird duck you think differently your
job is to teach me to think like you
think so some of the things that may
seem super obvious to you for other
people is not so obvious
right if I look at even your the your
room so those of you who I can see you
know your your rooms like why does Zan
have Captain America shield on his wall
you know why does Evan have Napoleon
Hill on his wall and Andrew Carnegie
Doug's Doug's trying to hold up Bill to
serve but it's being blocked out by that
by the Florida coast uh you know why
does Jeff have Steve Jobs up on his wall
right Michael's showing believe up on
his wall right like why why do you have
these in your rooms in your offices it
means something to you and that may be
like maybe maybe Zan's been a Captain
America fan since he was eight years old
I don't know like maybe that's just so
natural normal for him but for other
people it's kind of weird to have a
Captain America shield on your door
right like most people don't have that
so explain why it's there right explain
why you picked up this book most people
wouldn't know that that's Napoleon Hill
up on Evan's wall right so explain why
he's there explain what that message
means and and finding these micro
moments throughout the day from your
your routines your habits what you're
eating for lunch what happened when a
client emailed you like the way you
respond to things is different and so
that's your job it's not about how fancy
the the video footage is it's your job
to teach me to think the way that you
think and sometimes this is hard to step
out of because because for you it's so
natural and normal because you've been
doing it for a long time but for
somebody else who's watching you from
the outside it's it's weird and
different and that's the whole point and
so Instagram stories I think is the
easiest way to start just to get you
into that practice of creating content
again you know three to ten different
stories a day it takes 15 seconds Max so
you know at the minimum I'm asking for
45 seconds a day right this is not a
groundbreaking amount of time to create
content right 45 seconds three 15 second
stories a day
when you're ready to jump in and make it
much bigger
I would look at YouTube as my primary
home and then I would split up the
content to go to the different platforms
so when you can get to making one
YouTube video per week I want a 10
minute YouTube video every week and it
could just be taking me deeper right
Zayn has a 10 minute story about the
Captain America shield Evan has a 10
minute story about what he's learned
from Napoleon Hill Jeff has a 10 minute
story about what that Bullseye thing is
behind him right you know Michael has a
10-minute story about what believe means
to him right it's it's just taking me
deeper into it but the the Instagram
content stories is the first way to just
start practicing getting it
out of your head out of your mouth and
into the internet right into the world
um once you can get to 10 minute video a
week that's where I want you to be on
YouTube
because those that content will live
forever and then you split up the
content to go to all the different
social media platforms so until you're
ready to do that Instagram stories once
you're ready to do that then you can
still do the Instagram stories right
it's just add-on it's additive again the
Instagram stories are 45 seconds a day
everybody here has 45 seconds today to
record three Instagram stories to tell
me about something that's happening in
your life and and it's not this was
really hard for me at the beginning of
making content was it's not about
uh
uh telling me what you ate for lunch and
just kind of vlogging
it's trying to find a message in
everything so if you're showing me your
lunch tell me why you picked that thing
like why are you picking asparagus for
lunch or why are you having that
Donut for lunch like why why are you
picking that thing like explain to me
the thought process behind it right I'm
having the donut because I'm celebrating
my 50th birthday or something right like
I'm getting the asparagus because I have
you know I want to live a keto lifestyle
or whatever it is right like explain the
thought process behind the decisions I
remember when I first got started on
social Twitter was was blowing up and I
thought Twitter was stupid like this
looks so stupid people are just sharing
pictures of their lunch and cats and I
have no interest in just sharing I'm I'm
a pretty uh private person believe it or
not like I have no need for you to know
what's happening in my life I have no
need to share it
but when I realized oh this is actually
thought leadership content that the
reason behind making this book or the
reason behind having these pictures on
my wall it's not about me showing off
it's about me trying to help other
people think the way I think so that
they can improve their lives as well so
everything you've got around you is a
story that hopefully has helped you
improve your life some way now bring
that back to bring now bring that back
into the audience so that they can learn
from you like why are you here why did
you pick up Bill to serve what was the
biggest lesson that you got from it all
of these could be individual stories
that again teaches people to think like
you think so Stephen wrote why is it
important to tell your story Okay so
and built the serve we talked about this
right
people need to connect to you
if they don't feel like you know what
they've gone through they won't listen
to you so
you know Evan has shared a lot about his
story with uh alcohol addiction and
you know you would look at Evan like
right now and you would say oh this guy
looks like he's polished and clean and
knows what he's doing and has his life
in order and you wouldn't necessarily
think that he was addicted to alcohol
and and I know Evan's okay with me kind
of sharing bits of his story here on the
Stream
so if somebody came and was struggling
with alcohol addiction and they came
across Evan and he said hey here's what
you have to do these three things
they say yeah that's great man but you
don't know what I've been through
you don't know what it's like you don't
you don't I mean I'm addicted you look
at you you've got your life together
it's all sorted out meanwhile Evan knows
exactly what it's like uh to contemplate
suicide to to be you know massively
addicted to have a lot of self-hatred
because of of the addiction that caused
and so unless people know what you've
been through they won't listen to your
advice like Evan has some of the best
advice to help people overcome it but
unless they know his story about how he
came through that they won't listen to
him
because people will naturally think well
you don't know what I'm going through
and so this is where you have to share
your story where you've came from even
the journey that you're still on right
we're still growing we're still learning
we're never done learning growing
getting better and improving but where
did you struggle where did you come from
because ultimately your purpose like we
talked about and built to serve is to
help other people who currently are who
you used to be
right there are many people who are Evan
from eight years ago
I've intense we got two evidence in the
group I like using that as an example
right but there's also many people who
are Evan Carmichael from eight years ago
and that's who you're talking to and
that's who you'll love helping the most
you know Evan tinselman will love
helping anybody right and he's been uh
an amazing human in in the movement
makers group in this group even when we
first did our session in Pittsburgh uh
he was bringing value to all the other
people in the room he just wants to help
right he wants to contribute which is
fantastic
but helping somebody who
is currently struggling through alcohol
addiction is currently struggling with
self-worth is currently struggling with
uh potential you know suicide he'll love
helping those people more than holding
the door for somebody at a grocery store
or buying a Starbucks the person behind
him in line because that's who he used
to be and it's the same thing for all of
you and I'm telling them in the story
because I know it better I don't know
all of your stories you know in detail
but you've all been through something
and those are the people who you're
going to love helping out the most it
just feels so much better it feels so
fulfilling that you represent hope to
them that when they see you
and what you've come through
it represents possibility for them
because they don't see possibility for a
lot of you where you are right now is
impossible
for where Evan is right now it's
impossible he shouldn't be here he
shouldn't be doing the stuff that he's
doing right now it's impossible Evan
from X number of years ago would look at
this guy and say there's no way you're
going to be doing that that's not
possible
but he did it yeah and so have you and
all of you are here right now and the
version of you five ten years ago would
say that's not possible and so that's
your job is to show other people who
currently are you from five or ten years
ago that it's possible that there is
hope that you can grow that you can
overcome that you can climb out of this
hole that you're in
but without sharing your story to the
question that Stephen asked without
sharing your story uh nobody's gonna
listen to you so you've got all this
great information you've got the
knowledge the tools the the desire to
help the willingness all of it and you
can help and you know that it can help
but nobody's going to listen to you
because they feel like you don't know
what you're talking about because you
haven't been through what I've been
through right
so that's why it's super important to
share your story and and
um it's scary
it's scary to share your story it's
scary to put it out there it's scary for
people to know
um what you've been through you know
like using Evan against an example he's
has a super successful uh practice uh in
insurance and it could be scary to let
that out to have clients have customers
have Partners have people in the
community know that you almost killed
yourself and you were addicted to
alcohol right like now you're not normal
anymore now you don't fit in maybe as
much anymore it could be scary for
people to know what you've been through
um
but if you are silent it perpetuates a
silence it means everybody else who's
struggling with it they stay silent too
and they become afraid to share and your
willingness to share to be brave to be
courageous to put your story out there
inspires other people to say hey I'm not
alone I'm not the only one going through
this and it's okay to share my story too
so I see that as your all of you your
responsibility to be able to do that so
okay Esmeralda's here how do I overcome
the fear of being in front of the camera
or sharing pictures of myself well
where's Esmeralda Esmeralda we can do it
right now it's called turning on your
camera
hey we got lots of people hey there she
is Esmeralda
[Laughter]
it's one step look at all the high fives
and fist bumps and flexes you're getting
right I mean that's that's the start
uh so I do a couple things one
is I tell myself that being afraid is
not a good enough reason
you don't want to teach yourself that
I'm afraid and I don't do it I'm afraid
and I play small I'm afraid to chase
down my dream and then I don't go for it
because that becomes this negative cycle
that we repeat and I love that you're
like in a in a grocery store or
convenience store somewhere there well
they're all still tuning in to the live
it's amazing uh but being afraid is not
a good enough reason if you can catch it
like the reason I want to do this but
I'm but I'm afraid that just mental
break down that wall being afraid is no
longer a good enough reason because
everything that you want out of life is
on the other side of what you're afraid
of
every growth every opportunity every
breakthrough every client like
everything you want to do comes from
doing things that you're afraid of
otherwise if you're never afraid then
what then you
you stay stuck doing what you're doing
you just stay inside your comfort zone
it's just you're live photocopying every
single day
are you at your job that's amazing I
think she's working there it's awesome
Esmeralda joining in
I remember when I had my one of the only
jobs I had was doing data entry at this
company and they wouldn't let me listen
to music so it was back when we had a CD
what's a CD man it's like the Walkman
but for CDs like a portable little CD
player so I used to have that on the
floor and then I ran a wire through my
jeans and I always wore a turtleneck and
I ran I got an extra long extension cord
for my headset for my headphones and I'd
run the wire under my turtleneck and
just pop out here to get one little
soundbar to go into my ear so I can
listen to some uh mostly Andrea Bocelli
at the time while I was doing this super
boring data entry work so I love it I
love I love the hacks
um okay so to that question one is
fear alone is not a good enough reason
the second part is you're trying to
serve you're trying to serve you want to
help you're doing this you know you're
afraid to get in front of the camera but
why do you want to get in front of the
camera
take it from I wanna it's not about you
being seen it's not about you being this
big famous name it's about you have a
message that can help people you're here
trying to serve and whenever I flip it
to it's about the audience is about the
people who will see this is that even if
only five people see this video maybe
two out of those five people this could
actually be something life-changing for
them
it's not about you it's about them
that always gives me that extra little
bit of of confidence and push to go off
and do the thing that that I'm afraid to
do so I balance it between those two
things right I'll tell myself I'm Evan
christili Carmichael I do difficult
things or I do scary things or I do the
things I'm afraid of Plus
I'm here to serve and I'm here to help
and my message
can hopefully Touch Somebody Today it
may not but it's your intention going in
like the intention behind the action of
being in front of the camera is not to
screw people over it's not just to make
yourself famous it's to try to help is
to try to serve
and so I always take that mindset going
in before uh whenever I'm super nervous
uh or before and ever making any piece
of content it helps when you're when
you're even filming your own YouTube
videos because sometimes it's hard when
you're at home in an office maybe with
Corona you haven't seen any humans for
the last little bit and interact with
them and you just even here I'm talking
just into a camera and it's awesome to
be able to see your faces up here on the
screen
to remind yourself that hey this is a
video that's not just me in my office by
myself you're making this video to try
to touch somebody else's life and when
you take that as an intention your video
will be better
when you just focused on oh am I looking
at the camera and is my mic set up and
all this other stuff your video won't be
as good compared to if you actually
picture somebody
in your head I used to do this all the
time because I had a hard time getting
into the zone and I was making content I
would picture somebody and I'm I'm
making this video for him this video is
just for him and I'm speaking to him and
and that would Channel him as I pressed
record on my camera and I'd always end
up getting a much better video man time
flies it's crazy we already got time
let's get to let's get to like super
rapid fire
uh uh how to deliver the idea message in
a simple way
uh oh hot chocolate readings I would I
would do a 30 second hot chocolate
reading every day and post it to
Instagram
hot chocolate reading of the day and
then whatever whatever the whatever
comes at every day right every day for
30 seconds
um from Denise what type of videos go
viral in your opinion if you know if I
had a recipe for making a viral video
every time
that'd be amazing like that's what
everybody's going after but really be
looking at
make the video that you from five years
ago badly needs right make the video
that the you from five or ten years ago
badly means because the youth from five
or ten years ago probably wouldn't watch
an Evan Carmichael video
like oh that guy he's too energetic he's
too positive that can't be real I don't
know
you know like you don't want to listen
to those guys
but
you could you could touch you from five
or ten years ago in a way that Evan
Carmichael or Tony Robbins or Brendan
Bouchard or whoever else can't
and that's I think even much more
important than worrying about a viral
video that that blows up on the Internet
is having an impactful video that
changes somebody's life
so I'm still trying to make the content
that
uh that I need right now but also that
like five years ago Evan still needs so
that's always kind of in the back of my
head as well
I haven't since been saying disagree oh
okay your content helped get this Evan
to where he is now
well I love it thank you Evan appreciate
the love man
um love that five to ten years ago idea
brilliant yeah just imagine you
from five or ten years ago or somebody
who is like you and you're making
content for that person because you know
again Jeff from five or ten years ago is
thinking a different way he's not
doesn't have as much of a growth mindset
is
not wanting to listen to a lot of the
messages that are being put up there you
know he would look at what you're doing
now so that's crazy you know with books
on the shelf and Bullseye and all these
goals and accomplish like you wouldn't
think that that would be possible uh and
so you can reach Jeff from five or ten
years ago in a way that nobody else can
if you want to get a copy of build to
serve and join us live for our next
training with me to ask your questions
you can go get the book right there next
to me right there I'll see you there
I'll see you to get the book it's a good
one much love